hi today I'd like to talk about signals
and systems again at this point you're
probably familiar with the motivation
for why we're talking about discrete
linear time-invariant systems and also
with a few the representations that
we're going to end up using in this
course but you're still not sure what it
is that we're trying to accomplish or
where's the part where we get to predict
the future based on the fact that we're
capable of manipulating these systems
well we actually have to be capable of
manipulating these systems and at this
point we can describe its system as we
see it but we can't also manipulate its
representation in ways that make sense
to us so the thing that I'm going to do
today is talk about different system
equivalences and how to take a system
and solve for an expression that
represents a complex system and also how
if you know that some things in your
system are equivalent how you can
convert between them at that point we
should be able to talk about poles which
is how we're going to actually predict
the future so different equivalence is
that I'd like to talk about I'm first
going to briefly review the facts fit
last time we discovered the notion of a
system function great we can take a
representation of a system and abstract
it away into some sort of function where
we take the input as its given to us and
then multiply it by the system function
and then get the output that we're
interested in how do we deal with
something more complex I mean why is all
the way over here and we've got you know
multiple system functions and I don't
even know what happens here but it
doesn't have to be that scary let's
break it down one of the easiest ways to
approach something like this is to
identify each position where you have a
new signal or if you were to sample here
you would have a new signal and label
those values appropriately
you can then start with your final
output and then back solve for the
values that you're interested in as a
consequence of that final output in this
particular example y is going to be y2
plus y3 y2 is going to be Y 1 times H 2
where H 2 is some system function and it
probably you know is extracting away
some combination of gains delays and
adders like this one here y1 is going to
be x times H 1 and y3 is going to be x
times H 3
now I've got all my expressions in terms
of either Y or something for which I
have an equivalent expression for X so I
can do my substitutions come up for an
expression for Y over X in terms of H 1
H 2 and H 3
here I've just made the substitutions of
the equations above
and factored out the X if I wanted the
system function I would then just divide
by X and then I would have Y over X is
equal to this expression the thing I
wanted to indicate is that if I wanted
to abstract this away into its own box
maybe I wanted like a big H or an H zero
or something like that and it
represented what was happening in this
top line cascading two system functions
is the functional equivalent of
multiplying them together so if I have
an expression for H one and I have an
expression for H two and I want the
expression that is equal to cascading H
1 and H 2 I just multiply them together
likewise if I want an expression for the
linear combination of two system
functions applied to an input
individually like the combination H 1 H
2 and H 3 it's a summation of those two
values which is expressed here this is
the same as the relationship that we
reviewed in a very basic sense when we
were originally doing the accumulator
the only thing I'm attempting to
indicate is that that relationship
scales you know to an arbitrary level
complexity so if you need to you could
shift around these values if you can
find some sort of equivalence let's see
what happens when H 2 is equal to H 3
I'm going to take my operator equation
what this means is that if I wanted to
rewrite this block diagram I could do so
by doing
this is really similar to bubble pushing
if you've done six double oh four or six
double O two and have experience with
logic gates
I just wanted to indicate that it's also
a thing that you can do for block
diagrams and system functions there's
one more type of equivalence that I want
to talk about it's I call it feedback
equivalence here's our normal
accumulator great if I wanted to
represent this feedback system as a
feed-forward system what would I have to
do well the first time that I sampled
from X it would just be Y so right now
this diagram matches for the first time
step on the second time step if I had an
input from X from the previous time step
I would also want to account for it by
putting in a delay and then summing it
with the current value of X in order to
get Y at the second time step I would
want access to the starting value
the value from the previous time step
and the value from the current time step
and one more time to you know
exhaust the example at the third time
step
my output would be a linear combination
of the starting value the value from the
first time step the value from the third
to the second time step and the value
from the current third time step we'd
end up doing this ad nauseam to model
our feedback system so it's difficult to
do on paper but it turns out there's a
great relationship between these two
equivalences and things that we already
know from I want to say high school
calculus or possibly 1801 1802 geometric
sequences when we solved for the system
function we found an expression for our
feedback system
if I wanted to find an equivalent
expression using this feed-forward
system I would look at this infinite
summation of X terms
so if I wanted to know something about
the long-term behavior of the system in
terms of this system function I would
solve for this expression and then using
my knowledge of geometric sequences in
order to express the long-term behavior
in the general sense in this course
we're going to be looking at the
unit-sample response of a system what
that means is if the only thing I ever
do for input is a single value at 1 of 1
at time 0
then what does my output look like the
reason we're looking at the unit-sample
response is because it's a the simplest
way to look at the long term behavior of
a discrete linear time-invariant system
but the other reason is once we have
this we can also use it to do things
like make predictions about the long
term the long term step response and
other more complicated input signals in
the case of the accumulator if I input
one at time zero my output is going to
be one forevermore
that's reflected
in the coefficient of my geometric
sequence if I want to know what my
long-term response is going to look like
I can look at the coefficient of R and
make a decision about whether or not I'm
going to diverge or converge or do
neither so if I put a coefficient on our
whatever p0 converges to is what my
system is going to converge to so using
my knowledge of p0 I can make long-term
predictions about the behavior of the
system next time I'm going to go over
some general classifications of those
behaviors for the system and how to more
effectively use our knowledge of p0 and
how to deal with things like second
order systems